foreign
[Music]
Joe Rogan's new comedy club in Austin
Texas is still making big waves in the
news after opening just three weeks ago
everyone from Comedy fans to the Big
Time comics themselves have been in awe
at what Joe's been able to create in
Austin but it looks as if there's
already some new competition moving in
next door it was announced last week on
Instagram that another very well-known
figure in comedy who's a personal friend
of Joe's and even moved from LA to
Austin with Rogan back in 2020 is
opening up their own club in Austin as
early as next week this crazy kind of
situation you haven't even seen before
down the block there's the Vulcan
another block away there's the creek
there's another comedy club that's
coming up a couple blocks so in this one
space you can pop around and do five or
six spots only New York can you do that
you can't do that in La the place is
called Sunset Strip comedy club and
honestly I hadn't heard a thing about
this new mystery venue which is why I
was so surprised to find out that not
only is this place about to officially
open right after the mothership but the
new owner of this club is none other
than Joe Rogan's day one right hand man
Brian Redban he shared this image on
Instagram Saturday with the caption
reading quote cat's out of the bag proud
to announce I'm one of the new owners of
the Sunset Strip the newest Comedy Club
about to open in Austin Texas now I
don't actually think there's a rivalry
Brewing here between The Sunset Strip
and the mothership if anything red
band's been very supportive of Joe and
his new club over the past few weeks
plus even if they were to go head to
head it wouldn't really be a fair fight
Joe Rogan's apparently using all of his
resources to pay workers and comedians
incredible sums of money that were
previously unheard of in this field
making it almost impossible for any club
New or Old to try to compete with Joe a
lot of people don't even notice about
the club it's like Rogan's like I don't
even care if it makes money yeah I know
yeah he's like I just want to break even
you can't compete with that yeah I know
you can't it's like it's he he goes I
just want it I just want it to break
even think about that yeah he doesn't
need to make money dude he won't let me
say what it is but he said I could talk
kind of about it
but the way that he's paying Comics it's
bananas bro bananas it's like it's just
complete Game Changer huh like I don't
know how the other clubs will react yeah
because they're in it to make money
and he's develop a model where it's like
it's like he doesn't want to make money
Fair he's like I'm still gonna do the
Vulcan I'm still going to do like the
creek in the case which is the sweetest
thing which is very nice
doesn't it's crazy this is
work at the club a lot of people that
work at the club are Comics you can
check out your shift to go to a spot
and then come back another place in
another place that's wild yeah and then
come back in and the other place can't
be mad because Rogan will still perform
at your Venue yeah
yes he like took money from Spotify and
his glittery Distributing it to comics
in in an insane way obviously Joe Rogan
and Brian Redman are good friends and
with the way that Joe talks about
spreading the love and helping others
within your community it wouldn't even
shock me if Rogan helped redband open
this club to me it seems like history is
about to repeat itself the same way no
comedian had a podcast until Joe Rogan
changed comedy by telling everyone to
start their own show we might be living
through the next notable change right
now where all the biggest comics in the
world have their own clubs with their
own rules I almost guarantee that 10
years from now 6th Street in Austin is
going to look like the comedy version of
Broadway in Nashville just like how
every big country singer owns a bar in
Nashville that's named after them every
comedian is going to open a place in
Austin these guys all have the money the
motivation and the resources to make it
happen how cool would it be to go see a
stand-up show at a club called your
mom's house or whatever demented idea
for a club Tim Dylan can come up with
remember this video 10 years from now
this is what it's going to be and I call
it and who knows maybe the joke World
Club will even be open in Austin by then
some exciting news for all comedy fans
here at joke World we've had the chance
to partner with the great people at
watchcomedy.live to create an
interactive bracket style comedy
tournament for the members of this
community starting on Thursday March
30th you'll be able to click a link in
our bio that will take you directly to a
bracket with 16 different clips from 16
of your favorite comedians from there
all you got to do is watch each clip and
vote on the funniest ones it's
completely free you don't have to sign
up or pay for anything all you have to
do is click the link on Thursday go
watch funny clips and vote on your
favorite ones that's it the sole purpose
of this tournament is just to be a fun
thing for comedy fans to get to do and
build some camaraderie with each other
some of you know we tried to do a
podcast March Madness last year but it
was a mess the voting system was stupid
the seating wasn't thought out that well
and it ended up just becoming a
popularity contest this year will be the
complete opposite thanks to our
partnership with watch Comedy live again
we'll be posting a video on Thursday
when the link is live in the tournament
starts so if you want to make sure that
you get a vote and you're included in
this year's podcast March Madness all
you gotta do is Click turn on post
notifications right now guest spots from
last week your mom's house had on Brian
Simpson two bears one cave was Tom and
Chris DiStefano kill Tony this week was
with Bert Whitney Cummings and Jim
Norton flagrant had on Sagar and Jetty
whiskey ginger head on John Cena Bert
Kreischer was on Chrissy chaos and Adam
Friedland was on are you garbage on this
on this new setup thank you brother
appreciate it I can't stop looking at
this picture of you yeah he's going to
take a runx I don't like it I don't like
it wipe me up let's go looking right at
me right now
the eyes follow you wherever you go it's
really for lunch meat or something Jesus
Christ I feel like that picture's gonna
pass me
make out with your girlfriend
being a nerd it's all [__] what's up
Friedland dork that's my sister doing
she's all right
[Laughter]
this past weekend with Theo van had on
Caleb Presley The Joe Rogan Experience
talked with Andrew Schultz logic was on
the Honeydew bad friend said on Frankie
cunones Johnny Sanchez and Cristela
Alonso Roy Wood Jr was on the blocks
podcast Matt Ruby was on we might be
drunk Kyle Dunnigan was on the Harland
Highway and Ari shaffir was on you know
what dude so one time on his podcast we
were talking about it our our old old
fights I mean this is in our 20s I want
to wait before you get into your defense
which you've deducted to no defense no
you're defending I'm just saying kalila
was like oh I didn't hear this part of
the story 100 there's always a second
part that's why I want you yeah okay
what did he say he said I love both you
beat him up three times yep
as far as new stand-up comedy specials
go April 5th is the day that you're
going to want to circle on your
calendars because Big Jay oakerson and
Ryan cycler are both coming out with
brand new specials April 5th those will
both be uploaded to YouTube for free in
the meantime you can watch Mike
vacchione's new special on YouTube right
now or right after this video I mean
actually watch two more joke World
videos and then go watch Mike Vecchio's
new special please I'm sorry I look like
every cop that's been in trouble on the
news
foreign
make sure to keep an eye out this
Thursday we'll be posting the video that
has the link live to the March Madness
podcast bracket of 2023 so you guys can
vote on all your favorite funniest
moments and the whole goal of this
tournament is not to be like this is the
funniest clip so far no this is the
funniest clips it's just it's just for
fun it's just something that we can do
for fun because the college basketball
March Madness Tournament is happening
right now it's taking up a lot of
people's attention and time and people
are filling out their own brackets and
we love comedy all of us everyone
watching this video me you this
community of joke World fans we love
comedy the same way that people love
college basketball so let's just do that
with our favorite comedians and our
favorite podcasts and our funniest clips
we'll just get to vote on it for fun but
it's not like anyone's trying to prove
anything or it's just a silly fun thing
that we get to do because of our
partnership with watch Comedy live so I
hope that's a big success I hope it runs
smoothly uh the video that comes out
Thursday is probably gonna be titled
something like best of 2023 so far and
then it's going to be the 16 Clips kind
of in a compilation and then at the end
I'll be on camera just like this going
hey click on that link here are the
rules it's Mark's Madness baby let's
[__] go something like that so this
was a ridiculous ending to this video
[Music]
foreign